TIME FOR TONIGHT'S #HASHTAGWARS.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
ALL RIGHT, THE STATE, ONE OF
THE GREATEST SKETCH COMEDY
SHOWS.
IT WAS ON MTV IN THE 1990s.
WE WERE THERE AROUND THE SAME
TIME, ALMOST.
BACK IN THE 1900s.
>> THE 1990s, KIDS, THAT WAS
BEFORE WE HAD MACHINES!
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: WELL, IN HONOR OF YOUR
GUYS' SHOW, WE DECIDED TO MAKE
OUR HASHTAG TONIGHT
#SADTVSHOWS.
BASICALLY MAKING A T.V. SHOW
TITLE SAD.
SO INSTANCES WOULD BE "ALL IN
THE DEATH IN THE FAMILY."
OR "SLAVED BY THE BELL."
OR "RENO 9/11" WOULD BE ANOTHER
VERSION OF THAT.
(LAUGHTER)
SO I'M GOING TO PUT 60 SECONDS
ON THE CLOCK STARTING NOW, AND
GO! SHOWALTER?
>> "THE WHEEL OF MISFORTUNE."
>> Chris: POINTS!
KERRI KENNEY?
>> "HOW I MET THE GUY I THINK
MIGHT BE YOUR FATHER."
>> Chris: VERY SAD TALE.
POINTS.
MIKE BLACK?
>> THE BRAIDSY BUNCH.
>> Chris: WHY IS THAT SAD?
>> IT'S GOT "AIDS" IN THE MIDDLE
OF IT.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: VERY SAD, POINTS.
I HAVE TO GIVE HIM POINTS.
SHOWALTER?
>> "DOWNER ABBEY."
>> Chris: POINTS!
KERRI KENNEY?
>> THE BIG GANG BANG THEORY.
>> Chris: NOT SO SAD!
>> IT IS IF IT'S HAPPENING TO
YOU.
>> Chris: OKAY, POINTS.
MIKE BLACK?
>> FULL HOUSE OF CHILDREN
ORPHANED BY THE EARTHQUAKE IN
HAITI.
>> Chris: POINTS!
THAT'S VERY SAD.
KERRI KENNEY?
>> "AMERICA'S GOT CRABS."
>> Chris: TRUE STATEMENT,
ALSO A GREAT POINTS TITLE.
MIKE BLACK?
>> DORA THE BICURIOUS EXPLORER.
>> Chris: POINTS.
MIKE SHOWALTER?
>> CHERNOBYL 5-0.
>> Chris: POINTS!
KERRI?
>> LAW AND ORDER SPECIAL
OLYMPICS UNIT.
(LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE)
>> Chris: POINTS!
MIKE?
>> THE "TONIGHT SHOW" WITH CONAN
O'BRIEN!
(AUDIENCE REACTS)
>> Chris: POINTS!
THAT WAS A SAD THING THAT
HAPPENED, YES, DEFINITELY.